Друзі, всім привіт!
Поки в Україні відбувається перехід до сортування
і переробки сміття, в Німеччині це вже буденна реальність.
Ще у 80-х роках у ФРН були величезні сміттєзвалища просто неба.
Зараз біля кожного житлового будинку
є ось такий от сміттєвий майданчик,
на якому стоїть багато різнокольорових контейнерів.
В жовтий контейнер - Gelbe Tonne - викидають упаковку,
в зелений контейнер викидають рештки їжі,
і синій контейнер – для паперу.
А це чорний контейнер для несортованого сміття.
Я сміття сортую, тож мені нема що викидати сюди сьогодні.
Давайте прослідкуємо, що відбувається зі сміттям далі.
"Ваш персональний календар вивозу сміття на рік".
Такий розклад поштою отримують усі мешканці Німеччини.
Контейнер кожного кольору вивозять кілька разів на місяць.
У Бонні цим займається комунальна фірма bonnorange.
Видачею оранжевої куртки мене посвячують у сміттярі.
Долучаюсь четвертим до команди, і вирушаємо
на збір синіх контейнерів для паперу.
Ми спустошуємо 800-900 маленьких контейнерів
або 100-150 великих контейнерів за день.
Моя машина бере 9 тонн макулатури за один виїзд.
Збулася мрія дитинства. Я катаюсь на сміттєвозі.
Сміттєвоз повний. Тепер веземо папір до станції накопичення.
За день сюди звозять 250 тонн макулатури.
Бульдозер пересипає перемішаний папір до приймального бункера.
Звідти конвеєрною стрічкою він рухається до сортувальних машин.
Перемішаний папір на цій конвеєрній стрічці проходить через сканер.
Шум, який ми чуємо -  від повітря, що подається під тиском
для того, щоб фактично видути легший папір.
Далі - відсортовування стороннього сміття. Це персонал робить вручну.
На цьому заводі папір розділяють на три групи - за якістю паперу.
Фінальна стадія - пресування макулатури в тюки по 600 кілограмів.
Вартість тонни такої сировини на світовому ринку:
від 50 до понад 200 євро - залежно від типу паперу.
Ось бачите, не все в Німеччині ідеально.
Ця калюжа прямо на в'їзді до компанії Remondis,
яка відповідальна за чистоту.
Справедливості заради - Remondis, звісно,
спеціалізується не на калюжах. Це одна з
найбільших у світі компаній з ресайклінгу.
Зібране у Бонні пластикове сміття спочатку
потрапляє на станцію накопичення.
Бульдозерист Маріо штурмує гори упаковки.
Я підгортаю сміття ближче. Колега - далі на конвеєр, потім все пресують.
Процес сортування упаковки схожий на сортування паперу.
Однак сміття з жовтого баку розділяють аж на 15 різних матеріалів.
Незважаючи на те, що ця установка коштує 20 мільйонів євро,
без сортування вручну сторонніх предметів не обійтись.
Далі - барабан для відділення пластикових пакетів.
Електромагніти витягують метали, а інфрачервоні датчики
дозволяють посортувати пластик за щільністю.
Фінальний результат - от такий тюк із пластику.
Ціна за тону грануляту з нього – від півтисячі євро.
До речі, тут же на подвір'ї є автомийка. Адже після 8-годинної зміни
кожен водій зобов'язаний передати чистий сміттєвоз наступному екіпажу.
Супроводжуючи несортоване сміття з чорного контейнера,
несподівано  потрапляю до району червоних ліхтарів.
Дуже цікаве сусідство. Ось та червона будівля – бордель.
А цей завод із трубою – місце де спалюють сміття.
Сміттєспалювальний завод у Бонні щодня знищує 750 тонн відходів.
Їх везуть з усієї країни і з-за кордону.
Платить за спалення той, хто привіз відходи.
Зараз фура з Нідерландів розвантажується  у
накопичувальний бункер глибиною 15 метрів.
У бункері два крани з грейферним захватом перемішують
і утрамбовують масу для того, щоб вона потім рівномірно горіла.
Стану біля цієї штуки, щоб були зрозумілі масштаби.
Ось такі крани-захоплювачі перевантажують сміття
із бункера до камери спалювання.
Температура спалювання 1200 градусів.
З тонни сміття залишається 300 кг шлаків, які
використовують для прокладання доріг.
Енергію, що виділяється внаслідок горіння відходів
використовують для вироблення електрики
та опалювання будинків у Бонні.
Завод має потужну систему фільтрів, і з 98-метрової труби
виходять лише очищені димові гази, а також водяна пара.
Замальовка "Прощавай, літо" - крісло-гойдалка, надувний басейн
і парасолька від сонця ідуть під прес.
Раз на три місяці у кожному районі Бонна відбувається
збір Sperrmüll - крупногабаритного сміття.
Люди виставляють на вулиці меблі, які відслужили своє.
Ця потужна машина перемелює все:
дивани, крісла, навіть металеві огорожі.
Будь-хто до приїзду сміттєвоза може забрати те, що йому до вподоби.
Цим користуються і мешканці Німеччини, і жителі Східної Європи,
які приїжджають за меблями на мікроавтобусах, розповідають сміттярі.
От-такий чудовий білий диван стоїть посеред вулиці.
Якщо його не заберуть польські або румунські мікроавтобуси,
працівники bonnorange за 5 хвилин його знищать пресом.
Коли машина утрамбовує 9 тонн диванів, шаф
і матраців, час їхати до сортувальної станції.
Неймовірні відчуття: важка техніка нагадує
величезних залізних динозаврів.
Перемелені меблі сортують двома кранами-маніпуляторами.
Тут немає ніяких конвеєрів і операторам кранів треба
з ювелірною точністю відділяти дерево, текстиль, метал, пластик
і ковшом-захватом пересипати матеріали по різних контейнерах.
Цікава деталь: матраци сортують окремо, бо їх
не бере навіть сміттєспалювальний завод.
Дуже багато мороки із залізними пружинами.
Матраци відвозять на фірми, які спеціалізуються
на їхньому розбиранні і переробці.
Спустошення зелених контейнерів у боннському районі Мелєм.
Рештки їжі, перемішані із листям і рослинами,
висипають у резервуар, схожий на бетономішалку.
Він постійно обертається для рівномірного розподілення
процесу перегнивання і утрамбовування  відходів.
Після збору сміття привозять до заводу з вироблення компосту.
Температура  всередині - понад 60 градусів.
Бульдозер вантажить відходи до приймального бункера.
Далі сміття потрапляє до сортувального барабану.
Один з етапів - відсортовування неорганічних відходів.
Найбільше вибирають пластикових пакетів.
Навіть екопакети, які розкладаються упродовж двох років, не підходять для
органічного сміття, бо процес перегнивання
компосту триває лише трохи більше місяця.
Тож жителів Німеччини закликають викидати
рештки їжі тільки у паперових пакетах.
Далі крупні фракції потрапляють до дробильної машини,
яка перемелює все в однорідну массу.
Відсортована раніше дрібна фракція перемішується
із щойно подрібненою крупною, і все це подається до бункера перегнивання.
Тут розмножуються мільйони мух і стоїть різкий сморід гниття.
Одяг і взуття після відвідин бункера треба одразу прати.
За допомогою цієї спіралі перевертається маса,
що надходить у бункер.
Процес перегнивання триває 35 днів, і двічі на день
додається свіжа сировина.
На двір подається вже готовий компост,
який знову ретельно відсортовують.
Ми маємо абсолютно чистий компост – навіть без запаху!
На вигляд і дотик – як український родючий чорнозем.
У Німеччині високі вимоги до якості продуктів, тож
органічні добрива є дуже популярними серед фермерів.
Ціна за тонну високоякісного компосту сягає півтисячі євро.
А ще мені залишилося викинути пляшки.
У Німеччині для скла стоять окремі контейнери.
Причому скло теж треба сортувати за кольором.
Напис - для прозорого скла.
Тож цю пляшку викидаю в цей контейнер
зелені - до зеленого, і
коричневі - у третій контейнер.
Якщо вам цікаво знати,
що відбувається далі з цими пляшками,
а ще з одягом, взуттям, батарейками, електроприладами
та іншими видами сміття у Німеччині, пишіть
у коментарях і я обов'язково розповім
у одному з наступних випусків.